uns vor dem weissen haus wo jetzt donald
trump und melania trump gepflegt werden
wie es heißt guter dinge sein
herbert gibt es denn schon ein
lebenszeichen von donald trump eintritt
am heutigen tage aus dem krankenbett
außerdem twitter die ja in der nacht und
am morgen abgesetzt hat gibt es bisher
noch keine meldungen wie gesagt sein
stoffmarkt meadows hat als erster
offizieller des weißen hauses bestätigt
die infektion mit dem norovirus donald
trump ist in seiner privatresidenz im
weißen haus das ist genau jener teil
zwischen den beiden flügeln also der
hauptteil des hauses mit den säulen des
da gibt es vier etagen insgesamt und
zahlreichen räumen dort ist auch das
schlafzimmer und das badezimmer
untergebracht und dort eben hält sich
momentan mit seiner frau melania trump
jetzt auf weiß wir haben nur ganz wenige
menschen zutritt zu ihm natürlich leute
die ihm das essen bringen wie auch
mediziner die sich um seinen
krankheitszustand kümmern wie gesagt da
eher milde symptome wurden gemeldet
einer grippe ähnlich und was man auch
jetzt gehört hat von zahlreichen
aussagen und medienberichten ist die
tatsache dass donald trump
möglicherweise schon die letzten tage
symptome gehabt hätte einmal ist er auf
air force waren eingeschlafen am abend
am rückweg nach washington
das ist eigentlich sehr unüblich für
donald trump der ist ja insgesamt ein
energie irgendwo auch bei einem auftritt
beim spendensammeln am gestrigen tag in
new jersey wäre hätte er
niedergeschlagen gewirkt all das sind
anzeichen dass der präsident schon
einmal eine weile an dieser infektion
beide lass uns noch mal kurz über die
versorgung sprechen im weißen haus gibt
es denn da jetzt ein intensiv bett was
da vorbereitet worden ist möglicherweise
so was in die richtung oder ist er
tatsächlich ganz normal in den privaten
räumen und sollte es dann kritisch
werden würde es für den us präsidenten
in ein krankenhaus gehen wie muss man
sich das vorstellen
das werden die ärzte natürlich jede
minute jeden besuch jeder visite vor ort
genau bestimmen welches medizinische
geräte nötig ist im fall es ist
anzunehmen dass möglicherweise bereits
präventive medikamente verschrieben
werden medikamente deshalb ihr habt gute
erfolge gezeigt bei corona patienten
die ärzte müssen dann die entscheidung
treffen ob es ausreicht medizinische
geräte in die privatresidenz zu bringen
um ihn so zu behandeln sollte die
erkrankung schlimmer werden im
schlimmsten fall natürlich muss auch der
amerikanische präsident ins krankenhaus
es gibt jetzt kein voll ausgestattetes
krankenhaus in einem immer weißen haus
selbst jetzt haben wir gerade von dem
arzt gehörte das bike oder es in den
ersten tagen ganz gut aussieht mit den
symptomen und da ist leider die leitung
nach washington zusammengebrochen
herbert bauernebel ist doch wieder da
also die frage noch mal an dich herbert
wir haben gerade von dem experten von
dem arzt gehört wieso der verlauf
typischerweise ist beispielsweise anhand
von boris johnson die ersten tage alles
mit alles okay alles wie eine grippe und
dann geht's bergab
jetzt heißt das also für donald trump
der wahlkampf könnte tatsächlich
gefährdet sein und den nächsten duelle
könnten gefährdet sein kann man jetzt
noch von einem normalen wahlkampf in den
usa ausgehen kann man kann man nicht
keine frage hier vor dem weissen haus
versammelt sich bereit menschen jeden in
amerika ist klar wie ernst und
dramatisch diese lage ist so etwas hat
es ein monat vor den us war noch nie
gegeben so eine dramatische entwicklung
rund um den präsidenten es gibt jetzt
natürlich verschiedene spekulative
szenarien die man sich überlegen kann
das eine ist dass der krankheitsverlauf
milde erfolgt dass donald trump neben
zwei wochen lang aus der quarantäne
heraus einen wahlkampf führen wird
virtuell natürlich gibt es hier keine
wahlkampfauftritte was die nächste
debatte mit der oktober betrifft ist es
etwas schwierig denn das wäre eigentlich
genau zum zeitpunkt wo die quarantäne
von donald trump ablaufen würde das ist
wirklich fraglich ob es zu dieser
debatte kommt wie auch zur nach
folgenden debatte am 22 oktober das
steht alles in den sternen
aber so wie es aussieht da in amerika
wurden noch nie die wahlen verschoben es
dürfte den wahltag am 3
november geben und donald trump wird
sich wahrscheinlich bemühen so gut
wahlkampf zu machen wie es eben geht
anders ist natürlich in einem szenario
die lage wenn sich die krankheit
verschlimmern würde wenn er wirklich
schwer kranke dann wäre praktisch die
gesamte tram präsidentschaft aufs spiel
gesetzt genau das unser kurze über die
chancen von donald trump sprechen
beziehungsweise wie diese krankheit sich
auswirkt auf die chancen von donald
trump wiedergewählt zu werden auf der
einen seite ist dieses bild des starken
mannes ich stelle mich nicht an
ich bin praktisch immun gegen dieses
virus beschädigt auf der anderen seite
kann er ja jetzt den staatenlenker aus
dem krankenbett herausgeben sagen ich
setze mich sogar wenn ich krank bin für
mein land ein was glaubst du was wird da
dominieren
wie werden sich die chancen verändern
von deutschland es könnte einen
mitleidseffekt geben das ist durchaus
möglich es könnte auch sein dass dann
und haben das ganze zu seinem eigenen
vorteil verwandelt dass er wirklich
unbeschadet aus dieser carola infektion
hervorgeht dass er dann sagt das wäre
ich habe es euch gesagt dass wir es ist
ja doch nicht so schlimm ich bin selbst
erkrankt und bin wieder voll genesen und
kann die amtsgeschäfte weiterführen
wahrscheinlicher ist allerdings dass
szenario muss viele republikanische
strategen bereits formulieren dass das
jetzt der anfang vom ende der tramper
ist das ende seiner politischen laufbahn
möglicherweise denn natürlich weiß jeder
hier in amerika wie ausführlich donald
trump dieses virus verharmlost hat wie
er sich selbst geweigert hat alle jene
maßnahmen selbst zu machen die seine
eigene regierung empfohlen hat an die
amerikaner wie etwa das tragen von
masken donald trump hat sich hier
beharrlich widersetzt er hat das ganze
sogar ein politisches statement
verwandelt er hat durchklingen lassen
dass eben harte republikaner tragen
keine masken und die weichen demokraten
sind ängstlich und deswegen tragen sie
masken eine absurde situation natürlich
während einer
aber das alles diese zitate werden ihn
jetzt politisch einholen das ist das
zweite und wahrscheinlichen szenarium
einschätzung von herbert bauernebel live
aus washington ganz herzlichen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren